the panelists as as they are
as their videos are highlighted so um
so it's a great panel today so we have
um uh chris monroe who is uh
who's of course uh he's a distinguished
professor of both electrical engineering
eecs and physics at duke university
so he was involved in experimental
quantum computing uh
starting in the very early days
in the in the 90s in
in dave vineland's lab at miss boulder
and um you know of course he's he's done
a lot of work on iron track quantum
computing and in 2015
he um he founded the company iron q with
johnson kim so chris great to have you
on the panel um
we have mark zandry who is um who is on
the faculty at princeton uh
he's um
he's been on this on this colloquium
before as uh
as both as a
speaker and as a panelist he works in
cryptography
and
more uh
you know relevant to this particular uh
panel he
he's you know he is somebody who is
who's um
who's really led the charge on putting
post quantum cryptography on a solid
theoretical foundation and so um great
to have you mark um
there's uh levin van der siven from tu
delft who um when he was a phd student
at stanford he actually
did a lot of work at ibm almaden on the
on this early work on nmr quantum
computation
uh around 20 years ago
but more recently is pioneered quantum
computing
based on electron spins and
semiconductor quantum dots
and then we have a surprise
uh uh guest on the panel who's scott
harrison who
i'm sure needs no introduction here he's
been of course a speaker here and
panelists before but more more to the
point for this particular panel he's
worked
of course extensively on proposals for
um
for quantum advantage quantum supremacy
but also
um much of the
of the work um trying to justify the
correctness of some of these some of
these protocols
so um
so just to kick things off um maybe
could could we have um
you know each of the panelists
give give their
a few minutes reaction to the
the talks
talk boundary and dive as well as uh
as well as your thoughts about prospects
for moving forward with
with
you know verifiable quantum advantage
both
theoretically and experimentally
so
anybody would like to go first maybe
mark would you like to say
[Music]
um yeah i can go first uh
so i guess first i just wanted to
um
you know make a general comment that i
find uh really interesting about about
these proofs of quantumness
um is that not only do they give a way
for
us to
um you know test whether uh or confirm
that a quantum computer is indeed doing
something quantum
um but uh the these these proofs of
quantumnous have actually been used as a
starting point for tons of uh
theoretical protocols for quantum
cryptography and by quantum cryptography
i mean uh you know doing cryptographic
tasks that were never possible before
such as certifying randomness
improving quantum computation
quantum currency those kind of things
and i find it really interesting that um
sort of the the same underlying protocol
is sort of
you know being used for what in my mind
are two different things
um but also the connection runs um
the connection runs much deeper for
example the
the proof of quantumness um that we saw
today
the
the whole reason it works is that uh it
implicitly relies on the impossibility
of rewinding a general quantum
computation since if you could rewind a
general com uh general quantum
computation then the sort of same proof
of hardness
um that you had for classical would also
work quantumly
um and this this challenge of rewinding
quantum algorithms actually presents a
problem for the crypto community because
we're trying to justify the security of
cryptosystems we do it uh by reduction
but now for our attackers this uh
quantum being we try to apply the
reduction to them suddenly it'll break
because somewhere in there we had to
rewind the adversary and this is just
one example and there are certainly
others but
um i find the connections between all
these things very fascinating
um
i guess the other
thing i wanted to to mention the other
thought i was having during the talk
is really kind of around how you define
quantum advantage and there are problems
that have been discussed um um
somewhat widely say like uh scott
anderson on his blog has discussed some
of these like how do you
precisely define the point at which you
cross the threshold into quantum
advantage you probably can't
um
but there's also sort of a more subtle
definitional issue that um
[Music]
that this talk made me think of
which is uh which is the following so if
you can solve a
computational puzzle faster than any
classical algorithm like you can run
schwarz algorithm to factor integers
it seems very clear that you've achieved
quantum advantage if you can you know
beat all classical algorithms
um
but
things seem a little more subtle when
we're talking about advantage based on
proofs of quantumness they seem really
qualitatively different
um you know you're not
solving a puzzle you're proving that
something quantum is happening i mean
there was a question in the the q a
um
you know basically asking why you can't
prove quantumness by bell quality
violations and the the answer provided
is basically that they um in some sense
don't count because they require two
separated proofers
um so i guess it you know just makes me
i
wonder like how we should be
articulating what quantum advantage
means
um
in in a
in a way that sort of you know
you know naturally encompasses the
different approaches we have to
justifying it
yeah
that's great actually that's those are
those are great points in terms of the
spatial separation
my answer would be you know that that's
a perfectly fine way of doing it it's
just more
you have more assumptions built in and
maybe
maybe those are harder to justify
possibly you know
depending on depending upon the setup
but
but really
very
working um shall we
maybe you have a comment from from one
of the experimental listeners
or chris so
chris sure sure i can jump in i i guess
i will abstain from commenting
much on the uh on the on the talks they
were amazing
but i i do want to take the opportunity
to uh sort of um
explain the genesis of at least on
experimental side of our doing this
experiment
um and this started almost three years
ago um
in a conversation with norm yao i was
somewhere in europe i think brussels
some evening you know over a beer
proverbial beer and he said oh i got a
cool uh experiment you should try and uh
you know we we we're all raised on
shore's algorithm as the ultimate
proof of having a quantum computer right
he says it's sort of like shore's
algorithm but easier so so of course my
you know i i get very interested and he
shows me the x squared mod n idea and
the claw free concept and you know i'm
not i'm just a lowly experimentalist it
takes me a long time to understand deep
things like that um and
uh and then a few months later actually
visiting berkeley umish i had this
pretty much the same conversation with
you
um and this is sort of how our research
has been going for the last ten years um
we're you know i was trained as an
atomic physicist and i'm still doing
physics but
you know i like to think at a much
higher level you know we're we're we're
doing algorithms we're you know they're
still pretty small
um but just the process it took three
years you know well two years really to
get start getting data
and it's always the same uh the first
reaction is no we can't do that i don't
understand this the circuit's way too
long too many qubits um but you know
after
many months to a year in some cases
um with help from from these groups who
message the norms group and also uh toma
vidiq
you know meeting greg meyer laura lewis
and and the folks on on the teams and my
students talking with them we learn how
to compress the circuits and we just
learn a great deal and i have to say i'm
not i'm not commenting too much on the
you know
on how to how to prove a quantum systems
quantum here or
something about cryptography just the
way that the research in the field is
going and i have to say it's
i i find it super exciting it's like
being a student uh and you know working
on we're working on a half a dozen
projects at any given time in so many
different areas and it's just super fun
and i'm pretty sure that you know
eventually we're going to our systems
are going to get so big that we maybe
can't
uh uh simulate them uh yeah that's gonna
be a lot of fun i also i just this is
not really a plug but we have a miri you
know a dod big grant on
certification and quantum systems uh and
tomah is part of this message part of
this
uh and our team is part of this and i
have to say i mean this is for once i
hope no government folks are listening
too closely but like for once you know
this experiment is like totally fit
the uh the vision of that call anyway um
so so yeah it's been a great
collaboration i look forward to many
more
i'll be with that
yeah thanks thanks chris yeah it's
really been lots of fun to to do this um
[Music]
yeah sure i can say a few things well
first of all this was this was fun to
listen to the talks and learn
um
you know about about other ways of
trying to show quantum advantage in
particular
in a way that is verifiable i think
that's kind of the key the key aspect
here as i understand it um one thing
that i was wondering about about this
this verifiability of the of the
uh of these protocols is um aren't you
assuming that there is no classical and
efficient algorithm for prime factoring
or is that not the case here
uh and and i mean such an algorithm of
course we don't have but it's not proven
so so you know how how hard is this
verifiability that's one question that
that crossed my mind
um
then um i also just from an experimental
point of view is interesting to
understand better in these protocols and
also in these random circuits you know
where you sample the output uh which
which errors actually matter most you
know is it two qubit gates is it
measurement errors or state preparation
errors which which in the end impact
the the uh
the ability to demonstrate quantum
advantage uh the most
and then um
you know in the end i'm i'm really
motivated by by uh you know quantum
computers being able to address real
world problems of course as i think all
of us are
and and so um
what i'm also curious about you know
does this protocol you know which is
kind of connected to factoring etc
uh does that approach realistic
workloads uh better or more so than than
these random circuits that have been
used to demonstrate quantum advantage so
far it's also something that i'm curious
about and more generally you know what
type of protocols are really worth most
uh implementing uh you know
i would say
it seems a priori those that they're
gonna
that are that have a structure
of of uh algorithms that solve real real
world problems but maybe that's just a
bit too simplistic and there's more to
say about it so i'm also curious to hear
people's perspective on that
thanks
thanks thanks
it's
very interesting about that so you know
the first point he raised about uh about
having to assume the hardness of and the
bureau factoring that that sort of comes
with the terrain you know once you step
into crypto worlds
that's you know that's almost like
breathing you just assume that
as a as an
instinct so so that's that that's the
ground one builds on
uh
scott it will be
you know
great to have you here and oh well i
mean i mean thanks for for inviting me
uh
a surprise i i should confess that uh
today's talk was actually the first that
i had heard about this uh ion trap
experiment and um you know that this
this happened faster than i expected i'm
uh
uh it sounds like an exciting experiment
and particularly because it involved
these intermediate measurements right
which you know that that's uh i know
that that's a
a non-trivial you know interesting thing
to do experimentally you know even even
when it's just a you know a small scale
demonstration with the 15 or so cubits
uh but you know i'm i'm i'm a big fan of
uh this this whole you know research
direction of uh trying to you know
demonstrate quantum supremacy via some
sort of interactive protocol you know i
mean i was a
a fan of it you know from like way back
in 2008 when uh uh mick
bremner and daniel shepard were you know
talking about this this you know uh then
uh uh uh crazy idea you know even before
uh the the the there was the term
quantum supremacy right and and uh um
you know i guess that that term had a
you know had a decade long life span or
something and is now you know is now
deprecated but uh um
uh
so so for um um and and and and and i i
i really enjoyed both of the talks today
uh you know but for for me you know when
when i look at this you know the central
question that is on my mind is just you
know will this give us a way a feasible
way to demonstrate quantum advantage
quantum supremacy you know in a way that
uh is easily verifiable by a classical
computer and that will not require uh
fault tolerance
okay so you know we we you know we're
right now in this interesting situation
where we have you know for the past two
years we have seen uh claimed quantum
supremacy demonstrations with 50 to 60
qubits uh from from google from ustc you
know and then we have seen uh attacks uh
on those claims you know uh people who
say that they can spoof the results
classically uh you know and and and
which side you believe depends partly on
well what do you mean by what exactly do
you mean by spoofing what do you mean by
spoofing fast how fast is fast enough
right so you know we are right now in
the very exciting era where those are
all live debates you know and we hope
that uh you know and you know in the in
the near future the quantum devices will
will just decisively pull ahead to the
point where they're whether where
there's no longer any reasonable debate
about this okay but uh you know we we
can also see you know even just at the
theoretical level there are challenges
in getting to that point and you know
maybe the biggest challenge uh right now
is the cost of verification right the
current quantum supremacy experiments
that we're doing if we do it with n
qubits then the only way we know how to
verify the answer you know is
is like two to the n time and it's you
know just about as expensive as it would
be to spoof the answer and uh so so you
know i think it is a central problem to
figure out how to get around that now
one way to approach the problem is to
start with the kinds of experiments that
are
currently being done like random circuit
sampling gaussian boson sampling and so
forth and then figure out some way to
modify them to make the result
verifiable right to insert some kind of
cryptographic secret into you know an
otherwise random quantum circuit um you
know and i i've been thinking on and off
about that i i don't know how to do it
uh but what we heard about today was
sort of approaching the same problem
from the opposite direction okay where
you start with these protocols that that
uh we're we're very confident you know
would work would give us what we want
you know if we had a full you know fault
power and quantum computer right that
could you know do all of this uh
cryptography on superpositions of inputs
and then starting from that point we try
to figure out how to make it more
practical you know in the uh
in the near term how to implement it
with uh with with the devices let's say
that we'll have over the next five to
ten years uh so you know we heard in
this talk estimates of about 2 000
qubits you know to to actually get
quantum supremacy you know via these
proposals you know and i would say that
that points to the need for for further
theoretical progress right if we're
talking about 2 000 qubits then at that
point probably you know once you know to
get to 2000 qubits almost certainly you
need fault tolerance and at that point
if your goal is to like refute guild
collide you know refute the quantum
computing skeptics then you know you
might as well just run shore's algorithm
right and that would be the the uh maybe
the most straightforward thing to do
right but if that if that if those 2 000
qubits can become 200 cubits let's say
you know if the if the gate counts can
be reduced by some you know um i don't
know how many orders of magnitude it
would take okay but then you know maybe
we are talking about something that's
competitive you know for the next five
years okay so this is this is a you know
a very very live question you know i
don't know what the what the answer is
going to be you know i could mention you
know i just just this week i uh taught
in my my undergrad quantum information
class about shore's algorithm right and
i got the question that i always get of
you know how big of a number has been
factored so far and i had to say well as
far as i know it's still 21 you know
it's uh you know with high probability
is seven times three right um but you
know it uh um
you know it had to explain how you know
while you probably you could scale today
to you know running shore's algorithms
with bigger numbers than that you know
until you have uh error correction you
know it's uh uh you know it's not going
to be competitive right it's a limited
interest but you know i hope that that
one of these ideas you know will be
competitive uh for the near term but you
know i i uh uh i i i regard that as a
super duper interesting open question
you know maybe you know i just wanted to
briefly respond to this uh point that
mark raised about you know what is the
definition of quantum supremacy you know
there are there are many many you know
aspects of that question that you know
uh that are that are that are
interesting to to talk about but but
mark asked in particular why not the you
know about a bell experiment right why
isn't that a uh you know and and i would
say you know from from today's
perspective we could say you know what
what the bell experiments were doing is
that they were ruling out you know
trying to rule out local hidden variable
explanations of quantum mechanics
whereas what we're trying to do with
quantum supremacy experiments is
something more you know formally
incomparable but actually you know much
more ambitious in a way which is to rule
out arbitrary classical polynomial time
hidden variable explanations for quantum
mechanics
scott can i can i can i jump in with a
quick quick one when you say yeah i'm
fully agreed to do
um probably
an interesting problem certainly shora's
algorithm probably even x squared mod n
you need some level of error correction
but when you say fault tolerance do you
mean fully fault tolerance that you can
do
i i guess where i'm coming from is i
would only want to do as much air
correction as needed and no more
of course no i i was about to say that i
mean so somehow
the amount of error correction that you
need is whatever amount is necessary and
sufficient you know that you you run the
thing and you get the answer right it is
not decreed a priori by us
you know you know
at best we could you know theorists
could try to give some guidance about it
but you know you know the the amount of
error correction you know that you want
is whatever amount you need you know
that's the that's that that's the
ultimate arbiter
if if i can maybe also comment on this
point
um
so i i think that one one aspect that's
nice about these proof of quantumness
protocols is that
um similar to these random circuit
sampling tests and then testing with
linear cross entropy you also have this
constant gap between what the best
classical strategy can do and what the
best quantum strategy can do
and what's nice here is that as long as
you're above that classical gap so even
if your quantum operations have some
amount of noise as long as you're above
the classical gap
um
it would still require you to break the
underlying cryptography to achieve that
with a classical computer so this this
gives maybe some hope that maybe you
might be able to do larger versions of
these protocols without full fault
tolerance
and maybe also on that aspect there's
also a nice feature here that
i i don't really know how to think about
like i i think it might be useful but
i'm not sure
um is that
at least in in the learning with errors
based protocol i mean learning with
there is in in some sense already has a
sort of noise robustness um because you
have this um
noisy instance of some sort of linear
equation
and this is exactly the image that the
the prover needs to send back to the
verifier it's some sort of lwe instance
so you could imagine that even if you
have some level of noise there that is
not too great
that the verifier can still extract the
pre-images from that image
then it's it's still fine so it still
kind of tolerates some amount of noise
at that level
i mean if it wasn't for those properties
we would have no hope right
right yeah
it's actually the circuit depth on the
on this 2000 qubit quantum advantage
circuit
or the number of gates ballpark
oh i'm i'm not sure i think well i i
guess it would also be on the order of
thousands presumably at least in india
in in the lwe case it it would be
um also on the order of thousands okay
at least it doesn't go to millions or
billions
yeah
right um
yeah it also so one thing that's also
important in the lwe case so
the number of gates is kind of
determined by by your matrix by the lwe
matrix
and the sparser the matrix is the better
because the fewer um
calculations you need to do
so
it in some sense scales with how sparse
this matrix is so if if your sparsity is
um and of course there's also a question
of if the problem is still hard if you
have a very sparse matrix
but if if you can get a matrix that is
relatively sparse then you should be
able to still do it within a few
thousand
or like tens of thousands maybe of gates
and do you have insight in the question
that i asked earlier you know which
error types
are
um are worst
or worse uh from the point of view of
trying to achieve this this threshold of
showing quantum advantage
um
on that um
i think uh the just straightforward
answer would be most arrow are coming
from
the air the
partial measurement induced uh
mostly phase incoherence as it's
revealed in our experiment
um
i think from the experiment perspective
it's really interesting to see as you
can see from the experiment results that
are presented that's really something in
some extreme case it would strike down
the performance by even 50 in some
specific branch of the test and
it's from the experimentalist
perspective it's
it like reveals an interesting situation
like um when we so the system the
quantum computing system we've been
using in the lab has been designed like
that for a long time and we all know
onsen systems are
fragile so for many of the parameters
for really really long time
the design of the system has been to
restrict them to make them unable to
move for example we would have like
hardware implemented to stop the ion
chain from moving around if you stop all
the parameters if you like forbidden us
to have those parameters and in return
we gain stability and improved
performance those are necessarily
like
in theory restrict the performance but
now we see when we want to run this type
of protocol it really require us to
release a lot of those restrictions and
when we do that we found ourselves
walked into like a new way of running
this experiment that we never
experienced before that we never that we
don't have much experience before of
course there are many ongoing research
in this direction and
so that's why we see this new type of
arrow and
again reinforce like repeat the thing i
said but now at this point in this
particular implementation the one we see
like most dominantly is the
detection
stray light induced base error
okay thanks and and and more generally
if
you know if i tell you you can you can
dial down
or up the error on the two qubit gates
and trade it off for uh errors in the
measurement
um you know from the
from the conceptual point of view is it
clear that the two qubit gates are
always going to be dominating because
there are many two qubit gates in the
circuit or are there subtle ways in
which perhaps measurement or state
preparation actually
gets errors in those get propagated more
uh
again i'm not sure i'm yeah sorry so so
so let's say that that you have a two
percent error budget to distribute and
you can choose to allocate it across
state preparation measurement and two
qubit gates and one cubic case if you
want
is there is there is it clear a priori
what what the best distribution is or
where where the errors
hurt you most is it's just as simple as
there are many to keep it gates so
that's what you need to work on most or
is there or is there more to say
oh oh that's a good question um
in the previous experiment it's we would
always like compromise everything to
enhance the two cubic gates fidelity
well on one hand it's because single
qubit rotation are
of extreme high fidelity these days so
there's nothing really to compromise or
to lose so but the other parameter we
usually for this kind of deep circuit we
would always like emphasize the qubit
gauge fidelity it's kind of like
experiment intuition that
once the qkb gates fidelity was
tuned well the experiment would work um
for this experiment particularly
we see that
it's kind of like the detection
um so you have this partial detection
and you have this final detection so we
see that the detection actually
is very important is like
the
however
um which make it harder for me to answer
this question is from the experimental
perspective in this particular
implementation there doesn't seems to be
compromise or like a
weighing between
the partial measurement and the two
cubic feet of fidelity they seem to be
performed quite independently
maybe one thing i could add here is that
at least in in terms of the protocols
i'd also say that it
really depends where the error happens
regardless of what type it is because
for instance in the image register where
you evaluate the function and you get
the image of the function
we can tolerate some amount of error
precisely because of this
property of lwe and it's also true to
some extent in the other protocol that
even if you get an imperfect image
the verifier can still recover the
pre-images for for like the nearest
image
however if you have an error
in the pre-image test for instance so
even if a single bit of the pre-image is
flipped then you would just view that as
failure because that's not a valid
pre-image um
but i i would say that um indeed there
hasn't been maybe enough research on
um
how robust these protocols are to noise
so you could imagine maybe
um that you could say encode the
pre-images in some sort of classical
error correcting code so that um you
know you could at least when you get a
pre-image you could maybe do some sort
of majority vote on the bits or
something like that or apply some sort
of linear classical error correcting
code to get the valid pre-image
but then there's also a problem of how
do you
[Music]
robustify the equation test as well
we're there again if even a single bit
of that equation is flipped it's going
to give you an invalid equation
yeah so this also reminds me of one
actual correlation between the two pivot
gates and the partial detection is
because we use the emotional modes to do
two cubic gates the shuttling the more
like dramatic shuttling you do the more
disturbance it would cost to the
emotional state of the chain that would
make the
following two cubic gates that would
make the fidelity of the following qqb
gates
suffer
actually in this experiment we actually
would uh emphasize the partial detection
fidelity first because
uh interestingly in this protocol most
of the qubit gates are performed before
the interaction when the interactions
are down when the decisions are made you
mostly what left to do
is to
decide what the measurement basis you
would be doing in and
which ancella what is the truth of
choice of r as andrew introduced that
the verifier would make
so in this case it's like a cheaper
choice to emphasis to like let's go some
of the following two cubic base for that
but i could imagine in some other
protocol or algorithm that you would
require um
you would require high
like large number of gates after
interaction
you would actually sometimes compromise
the partial readout fidelity to give
yourself some boost in the qkb gates
quality
that's very interesting
that's really great
um
so thanks god you know as um you you put
your finger on the
the key issue there which is
whether
whether these these protocols can be
scaled without uh
fault tolerance and i should say that
this is really a you know
probably this is a good time to think
about this this question because um
uh you know we we've spent a bit of time
thinking about
how to
you know there are many
possibilities to explore and we explored
a little bit of that space
uh we couldn't quite get
you know they seem
potentially great simplifications but we
couldn't quite get them to work but um i
think that's really really uh you know
this is a really interesting open
question right now
um
i feel like if we if we theorists were
more responsible we would have had this
all figured out in advance of the
experiments yeah yeah i know
but you know we we we i mean we have a
culture where like half of theory gets
done in like the day before the stalker
fox dead
i don't know for my view you guys are
safely ahead
[Laughter]
well it depends on the point of view
right chris you could say we have
let's say 50-100 qubits and the
theorists are far behind in telling us
how to use them to solve a relevant
problem
[Music]
are there any questions
[Music]
okay so the q and a
has been
have been on set uh
um
you know
uh
if if
possibly we can we can we can wrap up
after if there are any further comments
from the panel
before we wrap up
okay so
in that case um
well thanks a lot andrew and davey for
fantastic talks
and thanks chris mark even and
thanks god for jumping on at the last
minute
it's been really fun
see you all in two weeks
thank you